foreign
[Music]
good morning and uh for those who will
watch the recording have a good day my
name is Kendall Lobby I'm the head of
solution on data monetization and
ability analytics at Google Cloud
I'm based out of San Francisco and today
I'm gonna actually present you one of my
favorite topics
we're going to talk about the business
of data so the business of data
cannot be presented without talking
about why data monetization
this is one of the most and key topic
for all of us in the data industry we
know how to transform data into
information but how we're going to
productize it
and learn how we're going to monetize it
this is actually a business model for
that so hopefully we're going to be able
to details your information
we're also going to talk about how do we
productize data with looker I don't
actually know looker but preo to Google
Cloud I studied actually my career my
career of sales engineer at Lucas so I
know there are a lot of Lookers in the
room and I'm very grateful for those who
who made it to come
lastly
um I mean not lastly but after talking
about productizing data how we're going
to use Luca
to power your data product we're going
to try to see what are the key features
capabilities of the product you're going
to be able to leverage right off the bat
in your platform and of course I'm going
to submit to these very very difficult
exercises to give you a live demo which
obviously just by the name of it should
give you a lot on how I feel
so why data monetization
I I helped a lot of customers
transforming data into into information
with many many bi tools and this is
actually my I mean my personal favorite
story that actually unlocked me to be
here today actually determinization I
didn't know anything about data
normalization I actually learned it from
you our customers because you're using
our tools and you're productizing it you
go to market and then you tell you tell
me you say hey Scandal we created this
data product this is how we're
monetizing it so I'm privileged to talk
about a company that is in the business
of what we call it's it's space to Cloud
basically the capture data for the
tankers so you know like all the tankers
all the shipment the the capture like
the latitude the longitude you know the
boat ID like a basic table correct and
the way they were monetizing data was
by just having an API and selling data
transactional like latitude longitude
but ID and there was the business and
there was like a four figure
subscription so companies like Maersk uh
you know hedge fund company could buy
the data so they can analyze you know
different you know Supply movement and
and ships movement also government
companies could track different boats
does that sound okay monetizing data
so we met we met with them and we say
well this is probably something better
to do to monetize these data so we
started to think about what how can we
unlock value to these customers when it
comes to optimizing for example uh the
route of those ships so we created a
data product
that allows us to visualize those
tankers in real time
so think of a dashboard where you have
you know we plot the ships
but instead of just saying well your
boat is here or your boat you know this
latency in the port the harbor of
Singapore or Busan
what we say is how much instead of just
saying to the customer it's going to be
100 000 per month or 100 000 a year how
about we tell the customer how much we
save them by optimizing the route by
choosing a better route so what we've
done is giving more insights
to their customers and proving the value
of the Insight saying like hey I'm
saving you on the fleet of like let's
say five boat I can save you 150 000 of
fuel if you take that route this is the
power of data manage station we are not
and you are not in the business of
selling raw data if you want to make and
I try to for those I know it's going to
be a fairly long presentation but for
those if there's one thing to remember
to make money and I mean
to to be to consider yourself making
money and and be a datamization
organization you will need to unlock
value to your customers that's gonna be
number one number two you will not sell
raw data
you will you will only be able to sell
insights
I sound very formal but you don't
you it's not a room
um another thing that with with my
colleagues and and our clients that we
we've learned from you is
by 2026 probably a quarter uh of 45
development company will have a data
product that will they will monetize
actually the example I'm going to give
you right now to illustrate this slide
is not a Fortune 500 company it's a CAC
40 company it's a the company is called
Carrefour uh they are a retail company
one of their Flagship data product is
called careful links and the productized
data that they resell to companies like
Unilever Proctor and Gamble Mouse where
they're going to basically aggregate all
their transaction and create a portal to
analyze the market shares of a product
but also analyze and access competitive
data so they can understand where to put
pressure on advertisement for certain
products so this is going to be
a prediction
but try to keep that in mind and the
pretty much every company a lot of
people ask me is it just a digital
native organization actually yesterday I
had a conversation at the booth from
financial company to very traditional
Legacy company even device company you
know like the I'm not going to give the
name of the company but you know like
the air filters that you have at home
like all the devices have now a mobile
app to prove and have charts to prove
that the air quality is better that the
temperature is lower but there's always
like proof of value
so now I talked a lot about demonization
but I also talked a lot about data
product what's a data product so you can
take a photo of of of what I I mean I
mean so many definitions of what's a
data product
my personal role especially when I'm a
little you know like today you know in
front of a big audience I always think
of a data product as an application
that has Analytics
some prediction obviously you're going
to use some machine learning artificial
intelligence
the last one is
even when you define this data product
one thing is missing here it's actually
the audience
a lot of people are going to build the
most sophisticated data product without
considering who is behind this data
product
so if I may I know it's always in real
time uh you can have great UI great
capabilities especially at the
conference you've seen all the
capabilities around artificial
intelligence machine learning data
analytics
storage stream streaming data never
forget when it comes to data analyzation
your number one
parameter is the audience
a lot of content here don't worry I'll
I'll I'll help I'll help you unlock all
the content here when it comes to
building those data products remember
data product have visualization
prediction analytics and an audience one
pattern that we've identified is in the
future and actually the future for some
is the present for some other companies
a lot of bi company
are going to become profit Center
business intelligence company or people
working in the data analytics are now
the analyze Finance data sales data
analytical data process data
disconnects you stay most of the bi
company are going to evolve toward a
model where they're going to become
profit Center all the insights they have
capitalized internally they will start
to create products
external to the organization
let me give you an example if you think
of inventory let's say I'm a business
intelligence person at company a I'm
doing inventory analysis
I can report to my manager this is the
inventory
this is the stock I'm in e-bike I need
to fulfill xlx0 now I can create a data
product inside the web application where
I provide for example on the e-commerce
page I can provide the inventory for
example for you and I can say well you
want to buy this e-bike my inventory kpi
says there are only two bikes left
so when I'm in the scenario of business
intelligence I can analyze my inventory
if I unlock value to you I can basically
create a new Behavior to speed up
your behavior of creating a transaction
and hopefully buying the bike I don't
know if there was a
eloquant
example but transformation from business
intelligence
from cost center to profit Center is
something that we see across the board
but I'll give you a better example
now
when we talked about databization I read
so many papers on you know the economic
Financial Times data is the new oil and
I was like wow that's I mean I talked to
every companies every day so I'm talking
to very very rich people every day
actually monetizing the data is not
something you can monetize data is a
potential resource
that only what only once you're going to
transform it and reach it
you will be able to monetize but how
you're going to do that actually there's
only three ways to Market your data
obviously I invite you to challenge me
when I leave the room but there are only
three way to monetize data
at the bottom the first principle is
called indirect monetization this is in
my personal opinion the thing that you
should save bookmark screenshot this is
the most powerful go to market motion of
data
in the world in the recognization and
I'll come back to it the second one is
direct monetization
and the third one is a combination of
both and I'll give you some more detail
but the diamond is basically indirect
plus the optimization and also you're
going to provide extra service to your
customers so it's not just going to be a
product it could be Consulting it could
be customer success but you're going to
help your customers understanding your
data so indirect monetization
is everything that you use but you don't
even know you're using it let's say you
are trading stocks or you are trading a
cryptocurrency or you're on a portal for
your real estate you're looking to buy
your house you see all those metrics
they're going to influence your behavior
for example you want to trade uh Bitcoin
you're going to see peer comparison
you're going to say oh today 80 of the
people are buying this stock for those
people in the room who are data
Specialists this is a peer comparison
analysis
once put in a product for a consumer
it's going to change my behavior and
confirm that yeah maybe I should buy it
in the recognization will only be seen
for consumers
what does that mean consumers like
myself we don't buy data like if I buy
like a a bike or a connected device I'm
not going to buy the data to know about
my performance
so if you think of I mean for all of you
in the room who are in the business of
creating an application
to consumer the only go to market
strategy viable it's going to be
indirect organization and what is in the
equalization is everything to do the
proof of value customer acquisition
retention you're going to basically
provide metrics that give value to your
customers but you're going to give it
for free
the
directation is going to be for
businesses what is it a lot of you
actually in the room have a enter I mean
for some of you in the room that are in
the SAS business you probably have a
freemium offer uh for small let's say
small small businesses medium-sized
Enterprise the further down you go to
the Enterprise the more you're going to
have data ethics package in your SAS
product so you're going to start selling
and upselling your customers with more
data products
and I'll give you some examples so
hopefully it's going to be a clearer so
my personal checklist that I go over
with every executive in the Bay Area
where or every customers I mean in the
world is
the following one
remember where we say sell insights and
not raw data actually every
database or any vendors in the planet
that says you're gonna just share data
and make money forget about it
subscription is typically six bucks
there's no tangible value
to Raw data
only a data product has a roadmap and is
self-regenerated by your ability to
execute upon those products so always
sell insights name your data product why
if you go on those pages of those
companies they say oh these dashboards
and reports whatever work you do it's
going to be commodity it's gonna be like
a coffee nobody will perceive the value
of your data product if you work on
competitive insights call it competitive
insights if you have sales and revenue
data product call it other Revenue if
it's a risk management Insight call it
risk management insights productize your
data name your data brand it and make it
evolve it's it's not just going to be
yet another dashboard in your product
third one this one is actually
fascinating
introduce every company that don't know
how to define what I call Golden kpis
will fail
what are the golden kpis using them
every day if you take your uh writing
you know your application to to use a I
was about to say Uber so Uber leave so
any other application you have a scoring
you have a score for you and for the
drivers this is what I call the golden
metric between your customer and your
company you need to have a contract as a
data product this contract is translated
by what we call Golden metrics when you
go to your financial your brokerage
company when you land on the page you
see your total your yield Patrol balance
for every every successful companies at
Google Cloud we've been working with
they are all able to Define between one
to five golden kpis
that's going to be really like super
super important I put some examples
scoring rating yield margin profit
inject proof of value
don't let your customers read the
results tell them hey I improve your
energy by X I improve your your yield by
X I saved you X prove them continuously
in your product that you make them you
made them better actually the business
of indirect Organization for for sports
for people who had you know wearing uh
wearables it's the business of I make
you feel better show them metrics that
make you that make your customers
feeling better and then the last one
drive user Behavior create some some
sort of events like hey
you have this plan plan one if you
change to plan two you would save x
amount like you provide
some metrics that allow your end users
to to move to one another plan or
another product
um the the second thing that I'm looking
at once I have my checklist is is
productizing it so you can see basic
insights premium insights competitive
insights people always ask me like how
do you know what's difference between a
premium insight and and something that
is basic insights well if I take let's
say A salesperson who come to me I can
say hey I'm going to give you your sales
performance but imagine the same sales
person come to me and I say hey I can
also give you
the performance of every other
salesperson on the organization this is
going to be very helpful because the
salesperson with their own result can
come to me or just come to this data
product and and talk to this person who
is the top performer to be like hey how
do you how do you perform so well in
this market
so this is a highly ranked in terms of
monetary value
and by having this approach of data
product it will give you also one
opportunity
it will give you the opportunity to
Target different audiences so many times
on the on the data product like you know
on my brokerage account
it's like the same dashboard for
everybody
um when you're going to create data
product you should actually segment your
audience a lot of you have clients that
are maybe small businesses mid-sized
businesses and very large businesses the
data product you design for them are not
the same some some of your customers are
going to need like Regional global
global insights and like maybe some
small companies they just need like some
very lightweight data product
sounds a little bit abstract
but uh hopefully I will give you some
examples and and uh and when you imagine
we'll do was thousand words
so we talked about data product but we
need to materialize those data products
so
on looker and I will recap what's look
up and look here is a cloud bi tool that
you'll be able to embed into your
application so out of the box within two
days one day two days three days these
are the capabilities that you should
remember that you will be able to offer
to your customers
so you will be able to provide them not
just dashboards because remember
dashboards are commodities
it's just a visualization you will also
be able to give them the ability to
explore data like I see the profit but I
don't care about the profit I want to
see the profit for this particular
product I want to see the product the
profit on this particular day so give to
your customers a way to ask question to
your data
so that's going to be the second one
exploration in my opinion probably the
the most most important capabilities
when it comes to data
third one API and is a typo so data is a
service that one is on me
or maybe it's a new word data as a
service we'll see we never know what
take as in for us
API and data as a service
every time you evaluate a business
intelligence to business intelligence
tool or data analytics platform don't
always think of what we vendors Google
Cloud included we offer you out of the
box we we offer those products for you
know Healthcare Financial Services
gaming
but what can you what you guys are so
Innovative what can you do with our
platform with the the API to unlock the
true power of a platform because you
guys are able to you know exactly what
workflow you want to build for example
you want to bring an Insight remember
what I talked about the the scoring
metric you want to maybe send the
scoring metric
to a text message why because maybe your
audience maybe it could be contractors
maybe you have a platform for
contractors they will never connect to
the dashboard maybe they will you know
they undergo so the API will give you
this ability to create new way of
delivering data where people actually
need it not everybody works like like us
like on a desktop and a laptop so it
would be unconsiderate to think that
your data product for tomorrow is going
to be a dashboard
last one similar notes
remember what I told you about the
Diamond Services for your customers I'm
sure you all have customers that say hey
I love your dashboard I love the extract
data that you have but can you send me
the this column can you share me the
date I want I don't want a daily report
can you send me by this country can you
send me by X also can you just send it
to me to SFTP I need to integrate the
data here but I prefer CSV like
and this is why we created a it's not
even a scalar it's really like a data
sharing Hub where your customers will be
able to choose which platform they want
to get the data which format CSV Excel
which column and at which frequents like
do they want the data when it's updated
do they want the data uh refreshed every
week so but let them choose
and maybe that's going to be a premium
offering for them like maybe not all
your customers will be provided with
these capabilities but this is what I
call often type the Diamond Services
these are your clients that know so well
your data that they want more about it
so you need to to be able to serve them
excuse me
foreign
so as I said this presentation doesn't
come from me this presentation comes
from you our customers and this is when
I'm actually of my favorite customers
that I had the pleasure to work with I
don't know if they're in the room if
anyone in drizzly of drizzle is in the
room uh I I mean Stacy did but hi
drizzly is an alcohol delivery company
you can basically deliver champagne and
of course non-alcoholic beverage as well
for those who who don't drink alcohol
especially for those who went partying
last night I'm sure today you don't need
a uh anymore called beverage but this is
a delivery application that has been
acquired by Uber in 2021 and when we
work with them they were doing business
intelligence they were analyzing the
sales data the sellable product the
trends like you know is the tequila most
selled in the like the tequila whatever
brand is more cell sold in New York than
in San Francisco and they were analyzing
all of that internally
so remember cost center
and what we said is how about we create
a suite of data products
that will allow us to go not provide
this information to the management
but provide this information to the
actual producers of alcohol the
distributors
so drizzly who is a b2c business
transactional delivering alcohol
created a B2B business of data and how
they've done that they created one two
three four data products
they listed and you can see here you can
read probably better than me from here
actually I have a another screen sorry
I'm not used to this setup they created
a list of business sensors they can they
can answer like basic sales data basket
mix competitive rank
and what they've done is they've ranked
those insights by monetary value
bronze silver gold Platinum so if you're
like the Heineken of the world the
constellation brand of the world you're
probably gonna have access to the
Platinum version of it
and what you you should think about
these guys didn't even have a sales team
to sell those data products so what do
they do
if you don't have a cell team how do you
make money how do you go to market
I see some people saying well yeah
you're not in a good shape
digital
it is it's a digital solution so what
they've done is they've given Platinum
to everybody you know why because they
didn't know what data product would work
so they gave Platinum to everybody so
they were not in the game of like
selling net new data product they were
in the game of retaining people maybe me
working as a distributor company maybe
I'm only interested by the trend or
what's been searched and for you my
advice is create
as many data product as you can kind of
like a bookstore create as many insight
as you can qualify them categorize them
because your client is going to be
within the company and they're going to
access for example the competitive data
for example all the time and these are
the customers you want to capture
don't anticipate on what your customers
want create a catalog of insights by
product and let your customers decide
what inside is going to be valuable for
them
as a side note on this use case
when they got acquired by Uber think of
a company that got acquired that has a
b2c business and also a B2B Data
Business so this is something that I
really want to emphasize on why is it so
important for you to bring on this data
product notion to your leadership and
not thinking about oh I'm doing bi I'm
just serving insights
remember I talked about indirect
monetization well this is indirect
manage station you see it but you don't
put a name on it they give you free
insights oh it's fun it's you know in
Mexico or in uh
um in in France where I'm from these are
the top five champagne that people drink
and this type of insights are giving the
proof of value and they give they give
to their customers a little teaser on
the full extent of their data product so
this is something that is done by the
best best best companies in the world
and you're gonna see it more and more
it's like top 5x top 10 top 10 best
product top best sellers and then they
start providing insights very very
powerful technique especially when you
want to create your go to market
strategy
another client that I love working with
also I love their their platform because
I'm not a very good website developer
Wix content content and website creation
they've created two data products with
Luca one is web analytics and the other
one is site sales analytics so for
people who build e-commerce on their
platform they need to provide they need
to provide a rapid way of analyzing data
so they've embedded looker with two form
iframe an API I have is everyone
familiar with the terms iframe and API
perfect yeah you guys rock you guys
should I shouldn't even be here you
already know all of my presentation one
advice I want to give you for your next
generation of data product never start
with a dashboard a lot of people come to
us they say hey do you have these
capabilities I want to embed a dashboard
no the home page is not meant to be a
dashboard it's you need to personalize
The Experience welcome scander here are
your top products that you're selling on
DC Commerce use the API create the
experience don't do a dashboard it's
almost like wow too much information
line chart pie chart maps and I mean I'm
also guilty to to be overly excited when
I create a dashboard by adding too much
content Wix only one synchronization one
business question one answer excellent
practice
another customer that I really love is
plentific plentific is a property
management tool they created actually 38
product data product uh with looker but
we don't call them you're going to say
well scanner they only have one product
it's the platform I'm logging in no
within the platform within your platform
your services you're going to be able to
create different data products for
different audience the data product
you're going to create for a single
property manager is different from the
data product that you create for the CEO
of a conglomerate of multiple
residential and Commercial properties
so something I wanted to extract for you
here remember when I talked about the
golden kpi their golden kpi is called
work in progress their platform helps
contractors to do the jobs on on
residential and commercial property like
fixing the air conditioner and fixing
the plumber the universal metric of
their platform is the edge of work in
progress so then everybody understands
it and the second metric that they are
developing is the score of the
contractor this helps basically their
contractor to be better at their job so
the platform helps basically
regenerating the potential and
optimizing the quality of services for
their community
Luca embed so we saw some use cases we
talked about remember data product
determinization
um and how to go to market but now how
are we going to do that with looker
well Luca will give you the entire the
full stack platform like from the
semantic layer
um to the uh to the business
intelligence tool to the self self
service exploration data sharing
capabilities you'll have all in one
platform from business intelligence and
also external facing products
it's going to be composable remember
what I told you about the future of data
analytics might not be a dashboard it
might be just a few kpis sent you know
text messages or in your instant
messaging system so this is something
that at Google Cloud We Care a Lot we
know that not everyone works of a
desktop and and web browser
intelligent well as you know at in the
Google Cloud family there's not just
local I'm sure you've seen a lot of
other products Luca connects to BQ
bigquery with machine learning we
connect with vertex AI we connect to
Google Map actually I will give you a
demo of looker with Google Map the idea
and the way I think of looker is an
ingredient that is going to be part of
your recipe when it comes to building
your your product so assemble those
ingredients like a chef and build your
recipe and that's what the platform of
Luca will be able to give you
for those who don't know what's look I
put a slide together so I'll go very
quickly we offer dashboard self-service
exploration
second capabilities that is actually one
of my favorite is all the workflows that
you'll be able to do is like send it
like if you guys let me work a lot on
instant messaging system just send a
dashboard to an instant messaging system
like you know I don't need to go log in
and look for my dashboard just send it
to the room where I'm actually talking
and having conversation with my
colleague last one this of the biggest
Trend I've seen growing for the for the
past few years our customers don't want
their data product to look like a
dashboard
and they say I want to humanize
information like if it's if it's a
sports analytics I want to see someone
you know with the bat I want to see
someone like you know racing the car I
want to have kpis like a video game
that's what our platform will give you
we are API first but I'll touch on that
more it will allow you to bring these
insights into your data application
without being restricted to the canvas
of the infamous line Child by child hit
map and and so on and so forth
those are great by the way this is data
visualization is very important but
um
I think this is something that I wanted
to disclose and show you because the the
everywhere we travel all around the
world people asking well because what's
the difference between Tableau power bi
Tableau and power bi you know the tools
are great products and I'm sure you a
lot of you are using them in in the room
uh I I it's I think it's just a matter
of of generation and capabilities our
platform is born in the cloud meaning we
have a semantic layer we are in database
none of those products were built
remember in memory we were bringing the
data and then Computing we are
connecting in the database leveraging
your data warehouses the computation
power of your database
and lastly we are web-based everything
I've been talking about is accessible
through one web page one HTTP endpoint
there's no like uh other product it's
one access to local platform
why is it so important to be in database
performances scalability was it
important to have semantic layer whether
you look at the dashboard or your data
application the the metrics that you
have should be exactly the same
one thing that also I would like you to
to leave is when you evaluate your next
embediting solution or bi tool don't
think about the visualization and how it
looks like think about under the iceberg
what you're going to find in database
architecture
the depths of API coverage look who is
API first the future of data
applications actually are an
intersection of different API API for
payment API for data API for geo
localization API basically all the
service that you have
Mission developer framework
semantic modeling layer this one is
actually Version Control like do you
consider your data product with software
development lifecycle or it's just oh I
have a request I'm just going to update
the dashboard now treat your business
intelligence and your external data
product like any other product on the
market software development lifecycle
iteration versioning and and those are
the things we offering and that I think
you should consider for your your next
data index product and of course the
customization and and action
quickly one of the flavors of embedded
analytics three flavors pretty easy to
remember OEM I'm sure everyone knows
what's OEM so you can literally take
Luca brand it with your company name and
all the colors and labeling Nami
Convention of your company and you can
go to market this is actually the fast
way to make money a lot of my clients
start and say hey Scandal we have an
idea we want to create a data product we
want to go to market like literally like
next week
build a dashboard offer them offer to
your customer to your top five preferred
and friend customer so they can evaluate
and give you feedback and you can go to
Market within weeks this is the fastest
way to go to market second iframes bring
the dashboard you build into your
application
last one API most sophisticated but the
higher yield the higher return on
investment more created seamless
integration
I will give you a little secret most of
our customers use the three of them
this is like there's not one better than
other it really it's going to really
depends on how how quickly you want to
go to market
I'm going to go a little quickly because
I really want to show you
a demonstration because sometimes one
image it was thousand words but remember
what I told you you're going to be able
to not only embed dashboards but the
self-service exploration capabilities of
looker
here on this screen all you have to
remember is with the API you're going to
be able to involve your designers your
web developers to shape the data
into information that will be translated
into for example here Baseball
application or or any sort of
application basically the gist of it is
don't stay in the dashboard bring the
data into your modern data application
for those of you who have a technical
background web Developers
I know how it sounds every time I go to
a presentation like this and I see that
they always say or API that's it so I
load myself to go a little deeper for
you guys what I meant by API is we're
going to cover the security of the
platform we're going to cover the access
to the data we're also going to cover
the administration like you know you
guys going to be able to create users
managing the product
and also you're going to be able to
manage the content like subscribing to
schedulers you're really going to be
able to create your own product
I provided some common API calls and
this is a preview of the of the
demonstration I'll give you for those
who've been to Monaco and like Formula
One you guys should should stay for
another eight minutes
this is a full Suite of the data I mean
not really a personal creation of the
product but it's kind of like the
recommended product that you should
think about to assemble to create the
next generation of data products for
your company looker remember data
application two interfaces one human and
one programmatic there will provide
insights to your clients
second one bundled with bigquery that
you know is like our high performing
Delaware housing cap and database that
will allow us to access data at the
light of speed vertex AI artificial
intelligence
platform that once Bend always bigquery
and Luca will allow you to augment the
services of your data product and last
but not least RPG remember what I talked
when I said all look API has data we're
going to sell data via API well you're
going to be able to provide and pipe
this API to RPG to create some
monetization strategy around
API calls you know like those products
they say hey I sell you 1 million API
calls or you can use 2 million API calls
so that's what the APG will help you to
do so
you guys okay I know it's not it's a
long day three days
I can see everyone is fine
awesome I see Samsung thank you
so who are the Target and who are the
people because of course you guys came
from the conference not everyone is here
with you and I'm sure you guys missed
some of your colleagues so who who who
we want to help with this platform well
we want to help like you in the room the
builders we want to help the product
managers content developers front-end
developers so everything we do around
our platform is for those people
but the second if not the most important
person are your consumers when it comes
to data monetization so we want to think
about to look to look good we want to
make a beautiful product for your
consumer whether it's b2c or B2B and
that's why we have all those
capabilities around B2B SFTP send data
to Google Cloud Storage etc etc so don't
think of us of like lightweight
visualization think averse of like
powerful Data Insights platform
so what do we do for the product
managers well for the product managers
we give them the ability to spin up
looker within minutes it's right off the
Google Cloud console you can spin up
looker build a dashboard
you have a link that says iframe
call your web developer and say hey
embed this
listening pad of code into the into your
product I want to see how it looks like
so you're going to be able to do rapid
prototyping before go to market
also and I'm sure it's very important
for you most of your customers are going
to be it's going to be multi-tenant you
want to make sure that there's going to
be single sign-on authentication raw
level column level Securities so all of
that is managed by your semantic layer
but we abstract all of that so it's easy
for your product managers to create data
products
content developers well we want to make
sure that whatever we build inside
looker is going to be added capabilities
for your customers so we are
continuously growing our roadmap and
product capabilities with visualization
they're going to make easy access to
insights but also branding for example
here you have the themes that we just
updated on our product available
basically look at to look like your
product
and last but not least for the front-end
developers what we've done is and that's
probably not for everyone but we have an
API Explorer but I also this morning I
actually use Bard I updated this morning
I used bot and I didn't know how many
local API functions we look and there's
like over a thousand functions of the
local API remember managing security and
the content so we we our API is probably
the most comprehensive
part of the product because everything
we built in Luca is first built into our
API so if you have developers that want
to help growing the platform we are
welcoming them and feel free to connect
them with me and and and our colleagues
that works at Hooker
oops
I think we've seen that huh
all right let's do a little demo
not kind of weird it's going to work
all right can you guys see Monaco so I
mean San Francisco is nice but Monaco is
not bad at all
so we let me actually set up the The
Prompt here a little bit so we so you
guys know what you're gonna see what we
thought about is how can we create a
data product by not just embedding
looker but embedding a lot of
capabilities Google Map bigquery vertex
AI what would be the future of an
immersive data application
that will allow us to analyze
like third-party data first party data
real-time data but also video data
you know almost like near near real
simulation
so what we thought is we're not going to
do a dashboard
we're going to use Google Map as the
canvas to put data inside so for example
right here
I'm going to analyze the data of my two
drivers I don't know if there are any
fans any fans of Formula One
and I'm sorry the data is only for full
disclosure 2019 so if you see right
cannon on the leaderboard that's normal
he's not back
so what we wanted to do is actually plot
data
on uh on Google Map I don't know if you
know about that but Google map has
released the capability called 3D
photorealistic that allows us creating
physical uh visualization where we're
going to be able to plot data and
remember what I told you Luca is API
first what other product is API first
Google Map you have two ways of
embedding Google Map API and iframe
looker API and iframe so what do we do
when you have those products well you
can blend them together
and by the way you you see this little
thing here do you know what is this
so this is not actually a Google cloud
or Google logo this is actually a Victor
vasarelli it's a it's a painting so the
reason why I mentioned that is a lot of
people ask me is that a Google logo at
Monaco and I say no it's a it's a it's
an outpiece from
1979. but it's just a coincidence
so what else you're going to be able to
do with this application well you're
going to be able to create remember what
I told you data product different
audience you can have the monitoring of
the of the racetrack but you can also be
in the cockpit with the driver and have
all the insights all the prediction of
like the tire strategy calculated in
bigquery that you render in the UK API
in order to display it with information
where you don't need to train people why
a mechanical engineer a race engineer is
not like me a specialist in business
intelligence tool they actually don't
care about you know filtering slice and
dice can be so painful here you come
what they see what are the metrics that
I need to care about and that's what I
really invite you to think about
defining your data product based of the
audience
and those are a couple of other ways of
of showing this application but of
course my topic was embedding Lucas so
how can you embed looker well there are
many ways of embedding looker you can
for example here I created some
visualization in Luca that I can add to
my application
and I'm going to make a little bit of
room here to add some other components
so that's one way to embed looker every
single visualization can be embedded for
rapid prototyping I'm not saying this is
going to be the perfect product but hey
I need the inside self-service it's
there pop it up in the application
another way to embed looker
is via API remember what I told you
about the API a lot of you analyzing I'm
sure data around you know booking
pricing Revenue bring them into the
application so I drill down into the
building get the data where it needs to
be don't let me look at Google Map
and then open another dashboard and then
another dashboard why don't you bring
everything together
speaking of bringing everything together
I also wanted to embed looker very
quickly I build a life frame and I edit
my iframe it's available in my
application so then I can have reporting
within my application
the beauty of Luca here is Luca can
communicate with your application if you
have already mastered filters like
parent filters you don't need to rebuild
them inside looker the iframe can listen
to the filter so you can communicate and
say Hey I want to filter and I want just
the data from Monaco
I think I might be over time but the
last thing I wanted to show you is the
exploration and all the things that you
can do not everyone will need to see the
dashboard maybe they have more questions
they are used to it they've seen it
every day in your dashboard they know it
they don't even want to see it anymore
so offer them capabilities that allow
them asking further questions so you can
see here in looker I have my catalog and
I can ask questions I want to see the
different reviews of the different
properties and because yeah I would
probably get the first one with 4.4
um
I know I'm over time so there's one
thing else that I wanted to tell you is
thank you thank you so much for your
time for your participation you made me
so happy today I hope you're gonna have
a great rest of your day thank you
[Applause]
foreign